die impfpflicht denn sie soll ja
millionen menschen zusätzlich von corona
schützen doch genau das bezweifeln jetzt
top virologen hier in diesem land vor
allem weil selbst zwei impfungen kaum
noch vor der ansteckung mit omikron
schützen wie sinnlos ist das ganze also
das ist unser großes thema jetzt bei
bild und im studio ist yvonne weiß
chefredakteurin hier auch ivan es geht
vor allem auch um impfungen für kinder
die impfpflicht jetzt so groß in der
diskussion kann es überhaupt noch
jemanden der sich nicht impfen lassen
will und wie stehst du zu der
impfpflicht wie soll überhaupt aussehen
wie weit wollen sie auf www aufbauen und
überhaupt auch mit blick eben auf die
kinder also ich bin tatsächlich für eine
impfpflicht weil ich glaube mit einer
impfpflicht für erwachsene könnten wir
kindern ersparen sich impfen zu lassen
also ich glaube in dem in einem notfall
oder im zweifel sollte man die
schwächsten in dieser gesellschaft
schützen und nicht die lautesten jetzt
werden impfgegner sagen wieso du musst
doch dein kind jetzt nicht meinetwegen
impfen lassen und da sag ich doch
zwangsläufig aus der not heraus denn wir
eltern stehen ja mit dem rücken zur wand
seit mehr als einem jahr schwebt über
uns täglich dieses damoklesschwert geht
mein kind in die schule geht es in die
kita oder muss ich meinen ganzen
arbeitsalltag wieder umstrukturieren um
planen weil es beim morgendlichen testen
in der schule und positiven fall gab ja
also jeden morgen schauen mein mann und
ich und viele andere mütter und väter
panisch aufs handy in der hoffnung dass
es nicht klingelt denn das würde
bedeuten das kind kommt nach hause man
kann die termine nicht so wie geplant
machen die arbeitgeber haben da langsam
kein verständnis mehr für das man
ständig alles absagen muss man muss
pcr-test organisieren und so weiter und
so fort die nächste quarantäne wir
sprechen hier immerhin von mindestens
fünf tagen selbst wenn wir nur
kontaktperson ist ja also ich glaube die
kinder leiden unter dieser krise und sie
leiden weil sich viele erwachsene nicht
haben impfen lassen und das zb im
dezember musste mal die ganze klasse
meines sohnes nach hause wo den
quarantäne gesteckt selbst die die an
dem tag nicht in der schule waren selbst
die die schon mal quarantäne corona
hatten denn man kann einfach die
infektionsketten nicht mehr
nachvollziehen und deshalb denke ich es
ist jetzt einfach so die kinder haben so
viel pech in dieser krise und jetzt
müssen sie sich zwangsläufig impfen
lassen die kleinen machen also das wozu
sich viele große mit verweis auf ihre
freiheit nicht in der lage sein also
eine impfpflicht für erwachsene würde
dafür sorgen dass sich kinder nicht mehr
impfen lassen müssten aktuell sagst du
wir wollen jetzt sagen ganz viele
politiker ja gut im pflicht okay ich bin
eigentlich der theorie dafür aber ich
krieg das gerade gar nicht hin wie soll
das gesetz überhaupt aussehen das liegt
mittlerweile schon mehrere wochen im
bundestag und keiner schafft richtig das
zu formulieren erst recht wo jetzt
omikron bei uns ist und eben auch die
zweitimpfung nicht mehr vor ansteckung
mit omikron schützt immer noch für die
impfpflicht über ich glaube tatsächlich
dass das logistisch kaum umzusetzen ist
darum geht aber es geht mir halt auch um
die kinder und wenn jetzt viele sagen
eine impfpflicht macht eigentlich gar
keinen sinn mehr oder nichts spricht
dafür dann muss ich an spricht aber auch
nichts dagegen
der impfstoff ist ja erforscht ich
vertraue der wissenschaft ja ich glaube
es kann wirklich nichts geschehen es
besteht keine gefahr und jedes kind das
ich beim arzt so anstellen würde dem
würde mal sagen reiß dich mal zusammen
das ist das beste für dich erwachsene
müssen sich anscheinend nicht mehr
zusammenreißen heutzutage ich glaube
tatsächlich mit der impfpflicht wird
sein wie mit der gurtpflicht damals ganz
viele proteste aber am ende hat es ganz
viele leben gerettet das sagt yvonne
weiß vielen herzlichen dank für deine
meinung hier bei uns im studio
und wir wollen auch immer noch
rausfinden wer sind die menschen die
sich nicht impfen lassen und welche
folgen hätte eine impfpflicht
beispielsweise für betriebe für
einrichtungen wo es besonders viele
ungeimpfte geben vertritt ja da haben
wir diese geschichte
46% ungeimpfte ja das ist die impfquote
in der lebenshilfe in pirna sebnitz frei
teil dieser verein in ostsachsen für
dieses unternehmen in deren 25
einrichtungen und 1500 menschen betreut
werden er hätte eine impfpflicht
katastrophale folgen da ein teil der
belegschaft dann wegfallen würde ja und
auch für die bewohner werde ich dadurch
ein tiefer einschnitt in ihr leben auch
für den stellvertretenden werk stadtrat
dieser städte in neustadt wenn mischke
der hat uns das erzählt wenn das halt
wenn man jetzt sagen würde okay du
darfst nie mehr auf arbeit kommen weil
es halt dieses gesetz geben würde würde
in meinem fall zum beispiel
wahrscheinlich wieder meine depressionen
foto kon stellen und betreuten
mittlerweise ist es im prinzip egal ob
jemand geimpft gewesen für uns für uns
betreute mitarbeiter
für uns betreute mitarbeiter ist es
einfach wichtig das verhältnis zu den
gruppen an und da steht an erster stelle
also man merkt an so einer impfpflicht
entscheidung der hänge auch schicksale
und wir sind jetzt mit dem
vorstandsvorsitzenden der lebenshilfe
mit ralf thiele verbundenen schönen
guten tag ihnen sechs cent pro logo
durch guten tag 46 prozent ungeimpften
sie uns erst mal bitte einmal diese zahl
ja das sind sie mitarbeiterin
mitarbeiter mit denen wir in den letzten
wochen monaten gespräche geführt haben
die sich andere für einen anderen weg
entschieden haben wie gesagt haben nein
wir lassen uns nicht impfen und das muss
man jetzt einfach mal zur kenntnis
nehmen
jetzt waren sie vor der impfpflicht
sehen sie es nicht um so mehr als ihre
aufgabe auch an die belegschaft ihre
kollegen und kolleginnen noch mal zu
überzeugen vielleicht mit argumenten
das haben wir getan und ich denke alle
viel pflege sprechen sind ja durchaus
involviert sind aufgeklärt habe sich mit
dem thema mehr befasst als man
vielleicht denkt und das muss man jetzt
einfach überlegen wie man damit umgeht
das ist ja sozusagen unser petitum
dieser angelegenheit die politik
aufzufordern jetzt nicht zu warten bis
zum 15 dritter für uns
selbstverständlich klar und überzeugend
dass die impfung hilft eine impfpflicht
helfen ob dieses verfahren bei uns
unterstützt eine aufrechnung der pflege
das können wir einfach bezweifeln aus
dem grund wollen wir das jetzt möglichst
schnell mit den konsequenzen umgegangen
wird wir müssen heute schon sehen was
auf uns zukommt und ist sozusagen unsere
aufforderung an die politik
sind natürlich wenn sich freuen wenn die
menschen sich in der einrichtung impfen
lassen würden was würde aber die
impfpflicht bei ihnen für auswirkungen
haben
die auswirkung pflicht können heute gar
nicht hundertprozentig prognostizieren
ob wir mit der impfpflicht wirklich
weiterkommen mein appell ist eigentlich
dass wir versuchen müssen neben der
impfpflicht einen plan b zu installieren
dass wir versuchen über andere
instrumentarien regelmäßiges testen
schutzmechanismen innerhalb der
belegschaft das alles was ja ohnehin
schon bekannt ist ob der impfpflicht
dazu beiträgt dass die menschen
weiterhin ihrem ihren beruf erhalten
bleiben also aus heutiger sicht habe ich
große zweifel ich glaube auch nicht dass
sie in pflicht und das eben bei der
diskussion in eine allgemeine
impfpflicht uns wirklich über diese
große schwere hilft die pandemie zu
bekämpfen danke ralf thiele der chef der
lebenshilfe dort in sachsen herzlichen
dank